Stay Close
is an eight-part thriller
available to watch now
on Netflix
that follows four
intertwined lives.
There's bride-to-be Cassie,
played by Cush Jumbo,
Richard Armitage's
troubled photographer Ray,
Detective Michael Broome,
played by James Nesbitt,
and Sarah Parish
as nightclub owner Lorraine.
Oh, and a huge
pile of bodies
growing between them.
If you've already watched it
and are trying to untangle
this web of lies
or just want to track
who killed who,
then this video
is here to help.
From the shock killer
of Carlton Flynn
to the bizarre antics
of Barbie and Ken,
this is Stay Close:
Explained.
And if you haven't
watched the show yet,
maybe do that first,
as this will completely
explain a number of twists.
At first glance, Stay Close
is about the search
for a missing teenager,
Carlton Flynn,
but the trail to his body
crosses with
multiple murders
and causes a few more
to take place.
So it's maybe easier
to break down
some of the mysteries
around that first.
Let's also keep
a death count running.
What are Ken
and Barbie up to?
When Carlton Flynn
goes missing
on the night
of a local carnival,
his dad, Del Flynn,
turns to the law for help.
He's an important
local businessman
and that applies extra
pressure to the police.
Detective Broome
is asked by his boss
and amateur magician,
Goldberg,
to make it a priority.
Take your coffee
and get yourself over there.
Little does Broome know
that Del, driven by worry,
has also employed
the services
of two theatrical assassins,
Barbie and Ken,
to search for Carlton.
Fed information
on the investigation
by bent copper Goldberg,
the duo hunt down
potential witnesses
and torture them to death
for information.
This includes exotic dancer
Tawny Allure,
and Harry Sutton,
a lawyer who looks out
for the dancers
and wrestles
with a drug addiction
that Del's assassins use
to fake a fatal overdose.
They also target Megan
by kidnapping her daughter,
Kayleigh.
But the enterprising
stripper turned super mum
manages to rescue
her daughter.
When Goldberg refuses
to help our pair
of harmonious hit men
any further,
they strangle him
and go after
their targets directly.
Big mistake.
Barbie is killed
in a fight with Megan.
And Ken is sliced
by Lorraine.
More on her in a moment.
The important
takeaway from this
is that despite
adding five bodies
to the overall count,
Barbie and Ken are not
part of the bigger picture,
although they certainly
make it a groovier picture.
Is Stewart Green alive?
When Carlton Flynn
goes missing,
it catches Broome's
attention for a reason.
He vanishes exactly 17 years
after a man
called Stewart Green,
an unsolved case
that still haunts the cop.
It's a serial killer.
I can feel it.
Stewart Green is the main
connective tissue
between Megan,
our mum of the year,
Ray, a jilted
photographer for hire,
Broome, the detective trying
to make sense of it all,
and the mystery killer.
Seventeen years ago,
before Megan was Megan,
she was Cassie,
an exotic dancer
in a relationship with Ray,
a man so love-struck,
he proposed with a plastic
ring from a crane game.
But Cassie was also being
stalked by Stewart Green,
an abusive punter
who would harass the dancers
and made her fear
for her life.
He stalked me,
and he threatened
to kill me.
He was crazy.
It's hinted that she and Ray
were involved
with Green's disappearance,
which is why Cassie fled
and reinvented herself
as Megan,
leaving Ray to obsess
over the one that got away.
Back in the present day,
Megan is visited
by Lorraine,
her boss from her days
dancing at the Viper Club.
Lorraine says she's seen
Stewart Green alive.
He's back.
He's dead, Lorraine.
But this is a lie.
She made up the story
to re-enter Megan's life.
But how does that explain
the bald man
in the dragon suit
who was following Megan
and delivers one of her old
dancing leaflets to her son?
This is a big,
bald red herring.
The mystery man
is Vipers bouncer Rudy,
who believes Megan stole
money from him and Stewart
17 years ago.
He still owed me my cut.
No, it turns out
Stewart Green was killed
17 years ago,
add one to the body count,
and that both Megan and Ray
thought the other
was responsible.
You'd already killed him.
No, I told you,
I was behind you.
Megan thought Ray
had killed Stewart
to protect her,
while Ray thought Megan
had killed Stewart
to escape him,
leading him to chop up
the body and hide the crime.
The trauma of the act
caused his mind to blank,
which is why
he doesn't remember
turning up at Fester's
covered in blood
all those years ago.
You were catatonic,
just looking
right through me.
It's a tragic
misunderstanding
that tore the couple apart
and forced Cassie
to build an entirely
new life as Megan.
I thought you were dead.
I'm sorry.
Who killed Stewart Green?
So, if not Megan or Ray,
who did kill the bald bully?
This one is a shocker.
Throughout Stay Close,
we see Detective Broome
investigate a number
of missing men,
all vanishing
around carnival time,
just like Carlton Flynn
and Stewart Green.
Most of us could guess
there was a serial killer
in the mix,
but would any of us
have pointed the finger
at lovely Lorraine?
Look how happy
she makes James Nesbitt.
Yes, Lauren has been
killing men for 18 years.
She started
with her abusive partner.
He had taken
my child's life,
I had taken his.
And when she saw the threat
Stewart Green
posed to Cassie,
she took care of him too.
What are you doing here?
Lorraine's mistake,
aside from murdering
nearly 20 people,
was to lure Cassie
to the body
by telling her Ray
was waiting for her.
This caused
the misunderstanding
that shattered
their relationship.
Also, because Ray found
and chopped up Stewart,
Lorraine couldn't
hide the body
in the underground bunker
where she stored
her other victims,
a whopping 15 bodies
to add to the death toll.
Oh, and it was Lorraine
who murdered Guy Tatum.
Ray thought he had done it
himself during a blackout,
but it was our friendly
neighbourhood throat cutter.
She was interrupted by
Carlton Flynn's forest chase
before she could
sneak the body
into her murder hole.
Speaking of Carlton,
Lorraine claims to have
killed the missing teen,
which would tie up
Stay Close neatly,
but there's nothing neat
about this sad story.
What happened
to Carlton Flynn?
And so we come full circle
and get back to our original
missing person.
Carlton Flynn was
last seen in Vipers
hanging out
with two masked girls.
They turned out to be
Megan's daughter Kayleigh
and her friend Bea.
Having snuck into Vipers,
Bea realises Carlton is
trying to spike their drinks
and switches their glasses
before escaping
with her friend.
The two run into the forest,
that's what forces Lorraine
to abandon Guy's body,
and split up.
Kayleigh leads the drugged
Carlton back to his car
and dumps him in the boot
before the girls
steal the car
and leave it in the forest
when it runs out of petrol.
This explains how Kayleigh
comes to be in possession
of Carlton's
distinctive necklace.
Kayleigh's dad Dave
then collects the girls
from the woods and decides
to come back later
and dispose of Carlton's car
in the lake.
He thinks he's clearing up
a petty theft
for his daughter,
but unbeknownst to him,
Carlton is still
unconscious,
spiked by his own drugs,
in the boot of the car.
Help! Help me!
Kayleigh doesn't know
her dad got rid of the car,
and Dave doesn't know
the body was in there,
so neither is aware
that Carlton is dead.
That's one last body
for our count,
and one last secret
for Megan to keep
as she puts the horrible
two and two together
on her wedding day.
And so we reached
the end of Stay Close,
with a whopping
24 bodies turning up
in just eight episodes.
If you enjoyed this show,
you should check out
The Stranger and Safe
on Netflix.
Like Stay Close,
they are based
on Harlan Cobain's
twisty thrillers.
And if you enjoyed
this video,
subscribe to
Still Watching Netflix
for more videos like it.